hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments ba ba do bop ba-bop eiope bop
me maletto what
quick make nom noms okay
can you tell me Marc why have you been
in a gay club before nothing against gay
people though otherwise I would have
said something against myself
lmao hahahaha well first off and I've
said this before I'm not gay and that's
not really anything to that I'm just not
that thing that that is and a lot of
people are probably gonna be
disappointed because no Jack and I
didn't form a beautiful blossoming
relationship while he was here we hung
out and we had a lot of fun going around
LA and making a few videos here and
there but as far as the gay club thing
goes I'm not a club type person and this
was all back in college anyway and I had
a lot of friends that were gay and they
wanted to go out so we just ended up
going to gay clubs because the the
typical Club is kind of a douchey
experience and a gay club is actually
more interesting and I got a lot of free
drinks so it worked out great for me ray
hey Mark
have you played five nights at sonic's
one two three and four no I have not
because frankly there's a lot of five
nights at freddys fan games out there
and personally I've kind of played them
out I'll play a few here and there every
other week or so but as far as making it
a regular thing to play all of them I
don't want to do that I don't want to
just play the game because the name five
nights is in there I don't want to keep
playing five nights at Freddy's games
forever and ever you know I had a
channel before or five minutes at
Freddy's came out and I have a channel
now not that I don't like it anymore
it's just that it doesn't need to
perpetuate every single thing I say
which is more raging losing Ross's Mario
maker levels or I am bread I am bread by
a long shot actually maybe not by a long
shot but by a considerable margin there
was just something about I am bread and
it's stupid asinine control scheme that
just was built to make you angry there
was nothing happy in that game it was
all just a landscape of death and
destruction in my mind I know
ever want to go back to it ever ever
again and I did break controllers so no
it's bad for me I will die of another
heart attack damn it no mark I'm really
mad at this girl because of something
she said to me any advice yeah I got
hella tight' advice
yo relationship advice Master markiplier
here to tell you I have no idea what she
said but you probably deserved it
probably hey relationship advice master
markiplier here back again I killed the
other version of me from an alternate
dimension that gave bad advice of what
you should do is not take what she says
at face value no matter how much you may
or may not deserve it just go on knowing
that you are epic head butts everybody
lationship advice markiplier is here to
stay so anyone that once bad advice here
we go mark what's wrong with jack oh so
many things let me list the ways he is
dumb Irish
he's a delight I'm sorry mark
do you like Deez Nuts how was your week
with Jack and going to Disneyland it was
great I loved it
Jack has only been in America for
conventions so this was like the first
time that he's just been over here to
hang out it was totally platonic and
nothing happened at all
stop the fanfiction nah but it was cool
you know I haven't had a chance to
actually hang out with Jack and just
kind of talk to him on a normal basis
you know we play games together and
we're gonna play two more games you know
gmod and Grand Theft Auto are coming
soon
but you know it was just nice to be able
to hang out on back porch because just
last night we had Aaron and Suzy and
Ross and Holly and Barry was over and
then Kevin and his new girlfriend and
there was you know Jack and Felix were
there and and we're all just able to
hang out on the back porch and just eat
snacks and shoot the and just talk
with each other which is oddly enough a
rare occurrence in this weird world of
YouTube where we don't get to interact
with each other all that much you know
we we just play games and we make videos
and that's cool and all but you know
it's nice to have some humanity to the
relationships it's really fun to see
these guys who I consider my good
friends in a capacity where we're all
together now that's not saying I see the
game grumps all the time and they're
super cool but I'm talking like Felix
and Jack being over at my house and
we're just sitting on the porch and
looking out at the city and just talking
about things that's a really good
experience so that's cool I miss drunk
minecraft and Bob and Wade bring that
bit back please
well unfortunately I can't I'll die as I
said in the previous reading your
comments video if I drink again I'll die
because when I drank before I almost
died and so if we did that again I would
die so I don't want to die so Horgan
just move on and so I don't die make
sense see the other video for a more
thorough explanation than that
epic Mar ow Rick have you even played an
instrument PS - trumpet soz mine
do-do-do-do-do-do-do you did it
why was Mark at a gay strip club now
that's just taking things out of context
relationship market vice guy here don't
go to strip clubs if you're looking for
a relationship and definitely don't go
to gay strip clubs if you want your
reputation on the internet to be
anything but solid wait a minute hang on
here relationship markiplier advice guy
number three you know that you guys died
cuz they're dead and I got rid of them
so what I'm saying is I'm not being
defensive about anything here I did I
went to a gay club not a gay strip club
want to be very clear about that hi sup
guys markiplier relationship advice
version 4 from the fourth dimension here
to tell you that the previous three were
an idiot don't listen to anything that a
guy looks like this says because it's
terrible advice for anything don't
listen to anyone named markiplier in any
capacity and if you see a Wilford warp
stash in anywhere near you run as fast
as you can just run and don't look back
what is the worst thing that ever
happened to you and I need to say
something
save up see it see okay while we wow uh
the worst thing that ever happened to me
I would guess would be the tumor that I
had I had a gang Leo neuroma the size of
my fist in my left adrenal gland if that
was too much personal information
too bad it's bad relationship advice
mark number five the other four are dead
they died they drank and then they died
cuz that's what happens - markiplier and
you didn't listen I told you not to
listen to my advice it's bad so yeah I
had a tumor and I told this story many
times but I had a tumor and it was right
before I did youtube and getting that
out was a because it was very
painful and not fun at all and also like
I was in the back end of a bad
relationship and like I lost my job and
it was just a whole bunch of bad things
happening all at once but hey I'm here
now I'm happy I'm happy
damnit I'm happy dammit your mail video
gave me a terminal illness short people
like you are the reason communism exists
your forehead is so large it's merging
into the five head range if I were
locked in a room with you Hitler and
Donald Trump and I had a gun with only
two bullets I'd shoot you twice your ass
must get jealous of all the that
comes out of your mouth I hope you step
on a lego without shoes or socks on may
all your bacon burn I'd love to slap you
but that's the animal abuse you're as
useless as a traffic light in GTA I will
be adding one new insult to each new
reading your comments video until - read
regardless of how long my comment grows
over time that's commitment right there
but two can play at this game you know
it's amazing how much ugly you've
managed to cram into a single face
scientists are trying to study it but
they haven't been able to make a camera
strong enough to survive looking at you
but hey I can only imagine that you were
blessed with equal amounts of looks and
smarts so thank you personally for
keeping your head shoved so far up your
own ass that we don't have to hear or
see from you ever again
Thanks have a nice day it's all good fun
people I'm not insulted by this and I
bet they're not insulted by me so hip it
boom relationship and lexmark I don't
know what the boom is but that's just me
coming in from another dimension
don't ask questions or else I'll have to
get rid of me too I don't want to read a
MIT boom relationship advice mark number
seven here those other guys were morons
don't listen to any weight on on--for
boom relationship the final relationship
it's my final form relationship advice
mark number eight I'm
idiot mark I plan on getting a tattoo
with all my fav youtubers and I would
love to have you part of it so is it ok
if I use your pink mustache or do you
prefer something different please tell
me hope
tell me smile that's totally fine if you
want to get a tattoo that's your
business and you're welcome to use
anything you could put my face on your
body if you wanted to that's time every
way aiming boom relationship advice
number 9 mark here uh yeah you can get a
tattoo of whatever you'd like you know
don't let me stop you I mean personally
there's only one tattoo that I'd ever
getting it's the same tattoo that my dad
got a few years before he died it was a
tattoo of like he was very patriotic so
he had like the big American flag with
an eagle soaring over it and they said
honored duty and courage so I don't want
to get a tattoo right now because I
don't feel the need to but if I were to
ever get a tattoo it would be you know
that exact tattoo I'd want it like
exactly the same way just to commemorate
my dad at the influence that he had on
my life so feel free to get whatever
tattoos you want if you want to get a
tattoo that's your choice and I got no
problem with it so best of luck to you
and I'm honored that you would pick me
to be a part of that alright so that was
the train wreck of reading your comments
number whatever I don't even know what
number it is at this point but hey maybe
they'll continue so thank you everybody
so much for watching and thank you for
submitting your comments remember if you
want yours read write it down in the
comment section below and thank you
everybody so much for watching I have
fun reading through these and have fun
making them so I hope you have fun
watching them and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye